hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei einer neuen folge
von easy german bei uns ist heute wieder
die wunderbare dana ihr kennt ja dana
aus vorherigen episoden und aus dem easy
german tipps dollar was fragst du heute
die leute in der oase heute frage ich
will sollte beim ersten date bezahlen
sehr interessante frage ich bin auch
gespannt auf die antworten und wir
können auch ein bisschen generell
darüber reden wer zahlt in deutschland
wie zahlen die deutschen ihre rechnungen
zum beispiel im restaurant das ist
interessant also ich wusste selber nie
das ist interessant in deutschland ist
aber ich kenne das von anderen leuten
die aus dem ausland kommen und darüber
witze machen dass die deutschen immer
sehr genau alles aus rechnungen sie
sammle ghent 70 prozent genau das werden
jetzt mal rausfinden los geht's
kann ich schon ganz kurz fragen ich
lehne deutschen wir machen ein
deutschkurs und heute fragen wir
wer sollte beim ersten date bezahlen und
war dunkel keine rolle wer warum soll
eine also keine ahnung ich bei der der
mehr geld hat soll bezeugen leichter
feldwehr sollte beim ersten weg bezahlen
sind beim ersten kann man das schon
aufteilen oder griff die 50 sagen
gleichberechtigung sind das sollte in
einer beziehung ja auch so weiterlaufen
da kann man ja von vornherein die
weichen richtig stellen
es kommt doch wann in welcher konnte man
sich befindet in deutschland sollte man
es wahrscheinlich teilen wenn man in der
traditionellen russischen verhältnissen
ist muss wahrscheinlich der mann
bezahlen
und was denken sie na ja wie gesagt muss
die leute auf weil die leute nicht
überfordern
im prinzip sollte mal der bezahlen der
am meisten geld hat hat er hat
eingeladen zum date das ist wichtig also
wenn ich dich jetzt fragen würde ob du
mit mir ausgehen dann würde ich schon
bezahlen
aber ich würde es nicht für andere
entscheiden das würde ich für mich
entscheidend geteilt vielleicht warum
nicht also ich meine es gibt ja
keinerlei verpflichtungen dem dem ein
gegenüber noch dem anderen also
ja
sind ja zwei gleichberechtigte person
will sollte beim ersten date bezahlen
der mann ja das ist einfach dann der
wand so der mann sollte bezahlen und
warum weiß ich das so gehört als
gentleman
wieso in deutschland es ist oft dass der
mann bezahlt oder ja so einige
emanzipierte frauen sagen sie zahlen die
wir selber aber eigentlich zeigt der
mann keine ahnung
und warum weil es noch nicht so eine
verbindliche situation ist ja beim
zweiten dritten mal dann schon der mann
würde ich sagen die frau auf keinen fall
und lieber jeder selber ok und
vielleicht vorher ausmachen
darüber sprechen vorher
und dann gibt es keine komische
situation will sollte beim ersten date
bezahlen natürlich die frau okay die
emanzipation
denken sie in general dass das anders
ist in deutschland aus in andere länder
das muss so sein also beide getrennt
dann oder man lädt sich gegenseitig
einhalten man geht so erst was erst dann
zahlt der mann und dann geht noch was
trinken und die frau zahlen die er so
ich kenne es so dass oft die sachen
leute sagen ich lade ich ein und sagt
dann nein ich lad ich irgendeine bezahlt
dann wenn ich auf ein date gehen würde
würde ich wahrscheinlich zumindest
anbieten zu bezahlen
alles aber ich fänd's total in ordnung
das mädchen und sagt hey ich bin selber
sage klar warum nicht
der der einlädt
seine idee ist oder ihre idee ist und in
generell denken sie dass das anders ist
in deutschland aus in alle lande ich
denke mal dass zugleich die menschen
sind ja letztendlich gleich wohin firmen
sieht man dann oft dass der mann bezahlt
ja oder genau eben klassischerweise ein
arbeitskollege von mir da kommt aus
england für den damen da muss der mann
bezahlen was weiß ich auf jeden fall
und er findet das ende kein date haben
wenn man nur unter kollegen essen geht
findet er das komisch wenn ich meins
bezahle und das ist für mich sehr
interessant weil in den usa der mann
bezahlt immer also also himmel
jahrhundert ich meine die frauen würden
denken dass er nur freunde sein wollte
wenn er nicht bezahlen ach ja also das
ist eine ok bezahlt nicht dann sind wir
nur meine freunde ihr bremsen
wenn sie dann weiter und wenn ja das war
schon unserer heutigen episode danke
bastian reiners besucher interessant
baaria 731 ich fand's außer interessant
und ja wir wollen natürlich jetzt von
euch wissen wer bezahlt bei euch hat
hattet ihr schon komische situationen in
deutschland in ihren heimatländern beim
date oder mit freunden wo leute
irgendwie komisch die rechnungen
versucht haben auseinanderzudividieren
oder einer gesagt hat ich zahle alles
schreibt es uns
in die kommentare und wenn ihr mal ein
paar videos von dana sehen wollt sie
macht sehr viele populäre videos über
das leben als amerikaner oder als
ausländer generell in deutschland was
ist komisch in deutschland was ist
wichtig ja es gibt hier sehr viele
sachen die auch die man gar nicht so
merkte dass sein hielt sie leben darum
diese liebe es dann guckt auf jeden fall
mal hier vorne rein beim video von dana
von ohren ein adventure her ging danke
fürs zuschauen und wenn ihr sie denn
unterstützung richtet freuen wir uns
über eine spende beim patchen und über
eine subskription ihren abonnieren
wir sind jetzt gerade fertig mit dem
dreh und jetzt kommt die sonne raus
tolle nach zwei stunden regel jetzt die
sonne